معنى من لندن مراسل جزيره محمد المدهون
محمد اول طائره وصلت اذن ولكن عمليات
الاجلاء ستستمر
نعم بالفعل عثمان وهذه هي الطائره الاولى
التي هبطت هنا في لندن لا تقل سوى اربعين
شخصا بحسب المصادر الاعلاميه البريطانيه
التي تتابع عن قرب في مطار سانسد ونحن
نتحدث عن اربعين شخصا من اصل اربعه الاف
بريطانيه بحسب التقديرات هم موجودون
عالقون في السودان نصفهم بحسب الخارجيه
البريطانيه نحو الفيبريطاني سجلوا اسمائهم
وابدوا رغبتهم بالمغادره والخروج
والذهاب نحو هذه القاعده الجويه التي
يستخدمها السلاح الجو الملكي البريطاني
قرب العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم لنقل
البريطانيين العالقين هناك حقيقه هناك
الكثير من الانتقادات للحكومه التي تدافع
عن نفسها وتقول انها تبدل كل ما يمكنها
فعله خلال هذه الساعات التي وصفها رئيس
الوزراء ريشوسونك بانها حاسمه ساعات
الاربع والعشرين الاولى من
هدنه هشه تستمر ثلاثه ايام نحن تقريبا
تجاوزنا منتصف مهله هذه الهدنه ولكن حتى
الان بحسب مكتب رئيس الوزراء لم يغادر من
البريطانيين السودان سوى 300 شخص العشرات
منهم وصلوا هنا الى لندن والاخرون ما
زالوا في قبرص وبحسبه بسيطه فان هناك عملا
كبيرا ما زال مطلوبا من البريطانيين من
الحكومه البريطانيه من القوات البريطانيه
الموجوده على الارض التي اكد وزير الدفاع
عن نحو 120 جنديا بريطانيا صاروا موجودين
في السودان وسيتسلمون القاعده الجويه التي
تشرف عليها القوات الالمانيه لتسيير هذه
الرحلات الجويه الخاصه ولكن كل ذلك
رهن
الواقع على الارض والتطورات الميدانيه
التي قد تنفجر في اي لحظه وقد تعرقل هذه
الجهود بما يحرم هؤلاء البريطانيين الذين
ما زالوا عالقين هناك من فرصه المغادره في
الوقت المناسب
طبعا ولكن هذه هي البدايه لا شك ان
الرعايه البريطانيين في السودان اكثر من
ذلك والعراق العلاقه تاريخيه وتمتد ولعل
من يذهب الى بيت السودان الذي القريب جدا
من باكن باريس يدرك معنى ذلك شكرا لك محمد
المدهون من لندن